Deep underneath Transylvania is a huge subterranean cavern
where something very strange is happening.
Strange and totally amazing!
It’s hard to understate the historical value of salt.
Wars were fought over it, people founded entire cities around it.
At one point it was worth its weight in gold!
But today it’s common place and this leaves salt mines in a weird place.
You’re left with this huge cavernous space that you’re not sure what to do with.
Well, in Transylvania, Romania,
they decided to do something incredible with their salt mine.
It looks like this.
Welcome to Salina Turda.
Tourists enter the mine
through a centuries old vertical shaft.
And as they descend,
it’s like they’re going into some sort of
futuristic, subterranean world that had to be built after a great apocalypse,
restarting humanity underground.
It has this kind of Blade Runner, Mole People thing going on.
And what do you find in this futuristic landscape?
Well at about 140 feet below the surface you'll find mini-golf,
ping pong
basketball hoops, bowling,
there’s a hundred person amphitheater in there.
You enter this vast enormous space and at the bottom of it
there’s a salt lake with an island of salt piled up in the middle
where you can go and rent a rowboat and row out to that little island.
And then next to that there’s a giant Ferris wheel that’s lit up and spinning.
And it’s all happening deep underground in Transylvania!
What they’ve done is taken this mine
and turned it into a museum of the history of mining.
But really it’s a sort of general purpose theme park with
all kinds of amusements in it.
We should go.
Why are we not going?
Subscribe here
and watch more videos here.